I'm Kevin Keller the editorial  cartoonist for The Economist magazine  for the past 44 years and today I'm  going to teach you how to draw Vladimir  Putin in 44 seconds okay we're going to  start with the back of his head like  here connecting to a very odd line as  you can see going down and across this  is the bottom of his jawline heading up  in his forehead now his funky  Stumpy nose leading to an angry little  mouth down here and the key bit of any  caricature of Vladimir Putin is the eyes  the angry KGB eyes that kind of tells  people it's him but if that doesn't sell  it there's one thing that guarantees to  sell this to anyone they'll know  immediately as Vladimir Putin have his  arm extended like this and his hand out  in front and then you simply  but blood  on his hands